Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking
in class a little bit
about parametric
equations and arc length.
So let's do an example
of a problem where
you compute an arc
length of a curve given
by some parametric equations.
So in particular, I have here
the parametric equations y
equals t minus 1 over t, and
x equals t plus 1 over t,
for 1 less than or equal to
t, less than or equal to 2.
So those parametric equations
trace out some piece
of a curve in the plane.
And what I'd like you
to do is write down
an integral whose value
is equal to the arc
length of that curve.
So the integral
you're going to get
is going to be pretty
hard to evaluate.
So I wouldn't recommend
you spend a whole lot
of time trying to evaluate it.
But just so we see that we,
you know, we can do this,
and so we have the integral
whose value is the arc length.
So take a few
minutes, work on that,
pause the video, come back,
and we can work on it together.
All right.
So I hope you've had some
luck working this problem.
Let's get started
on it together.
So in order to compute the
arc length by an integral,
we need to figure out what
the element of arc length
is, that little piece ds.
So this was true when
we had our curve given
in rectangular coordinates,
and it's also true
when our curve is given
in parametric coordinates.
So in general, the little
element of arc length
is given as ds equals the
square root of dx squared
plus dy squared.
Now, when our curve is given
in rectangular coordinates,
usually what we do here is
we factor out a dx squared,
and then we have dx by
dy, the derivative of y
with respect to x.
But here, we don't
have x or y given
in terms of the other one.
We have them both given in
terms of this parameter, t.
So the parameter t is
the thing, is our sort
of independent variable.
It's the thing we're
going to want to end up
integrating with respect to.
So what we actually
want to do in this case,
is we want to factor out
a dt from everywhere.
So if you factor out a dt, what
this becomes-- or dt squared,
I guess I should
say-- is that you
get dx/dt squared plus dy/dt
squared, the whole thing square
root, dt.
OK.
So this is just a little
algebraic manipulation
involving differentials.
And what this gives me is an
expression that will-- you
know, x is a function of t. x
is given as a function of t,
right here.
So dx/dt is a function of t.
And similarly, y is
given as a function of t,
so dy/dt is a function of t.
So this whole expression
is a function of t,
so we have a function of t dt.
So it's all set up
to be integrated.
So in order to actually,
you know, compute
with this formula, well, we just
take our y, and we take our x,
and we take their derivatives.
So from-- well, I guess
we could start with a y,
since it's on top over there.
So dy/dt.
Well, you know.
You just take a derivative.
Right?
So you have y is equal
to t minus 1 over t.
And you take a
derivative of that.
Derivative of t is just
1, derivative of 1 over t
is minus 1 over t
squared, so this
becomes-- but there's an
extra minus sign there,
so this becomes 1
plus 1 over t squared.
And similarly, dx by dt is equal
to 1 minus 1 over t squared.
So you have these
two derivatives.
So to compute arc
length, you plug them
into this formula for the
element of arc length,
and then you'll integrate.
So OK.
So we have to put them
into that formula.
So what do we get?
We have ds is equal to
the square root of, well,
so dx/dt squared
plus dy/dt squared.
So that's 1 minus 1
over t squared squared,
plus 1 plus 1 over
t squared squared.
dt outside.
OK.
And so now we, you know, maybe
we can simplify this a little.
I would probably expand
out, at this point.
So if you expand this out,
this is-- well, let's see.
The first one is
just is 1 minus 2
over t squared plus 1
over t to the fourth,
plus-- that's the first
one we expanded out,
and the second one,
we get 1 plus 2
over t squared plus 1
over t to the fourth.
All right.
And if we put all this together,
say, over a common denominator,
and simplify it a
little bit, we can
see that this is equal to--
over t squared terms cancel out,
and we end up with something
like square root of t
to the fourth plus 1
over t squared, dt.
OK.
So this is all this ds that
we've been playing with.
So the actual arc length is what
we get when we integrate ds.
So we need appropriate bounds.
So where do we get those bounds?
Well, we go back
to the question,
and here, the question
had to have told us.
Right?
If the question didn't tell
us, then it didn't actually
describe a piece of curve,
or a finite piece of curve,
really, is the point.
So the question tells us that we
want this from t equals 1 to 2.
So the arc length, we just
integrate our little element
of arc length over the
appropriate interval.
So that's t from 1 to 2
of the square root of t
to the fourth plus
1 over t squared dt.
All right.
So as I said at
the beginning, this
is not an integral
that's readily
susceptible to the techniques
that we've learned.
You know, if you
were interested,
you could try some
numerical methods on it.
I'm sure, you know, computer
algebra software can spit out,
at worst, a good
numerical approximation,
if you're curious.
One more thing I want to
say about this question,
is that we did all this without
ever trying to draw the curve,
or think about what
the curve looks like.
So it's not that hard to
get some sort of basic sense
of the behavior of this curve.
For example, when t
gets very, very large,
we see that what happens is
that x and y, well, the 1 over t
gets small, so x and y
get close to each other.
But x is just a tiny,
tiny bit bigger.
So for, as t gets
very, very big,
you see that the
point on the curve
is getting very close
to the line y equals x,
but not actually touching it.
And you can, you know,
you can try other things,
as t gets close to 0
from the positive side,
from the negative side.
So this has some sort of
asymptote, it seems like.
There's some other
things you could check.
You could try to show
that the x-value is always
either-- well,
when t is positive,
it's always at least 2,
or when t is negative,
it's always at least
negative 2, and there's
a sort of gap in between.
You could analyze
its properties there.
The other thing you could do,
is you could try and solve
these equations to
eliminate t, and get
just rectangular equations
in terms of x and y.
So I'm not going
to do that for you.
I'll give you a hint about
how I would go about it.
Which is, you could start off--
so you want to eliminate t.
So I think the nicest
way to do that is
if you add these two equations.
You'll get that the 1
over t's cancel out,
and you get 2t equals x plus
y, or t equals x plus y over 2.
And then you can take, and
you could substitute it back
into one of these equations.
And when you substitute
it back, then you'll
have an equation that just
involves x and y, which,
with a little more
simplification,
takes a form that you should
already be familiar with.
OK.
And yes.
Arc length.
This is how we do arc
length in parametric form.
Works out pretty nice,
except in this case,
we get an integral we can't
evaluate at the very end.
Too bad.
All right.
I'll leave it with that.